back in this country officials in
Memphis say police officers will be
disciplined over the death of a black
man after a traffic stop the Man's
family wants them arrested Tyree Nichols
died three days after a confrontation
with those officers officers say he ran
from the scene before he was captured
the Nichols family claims he was beaten
and suffered a heart attack Elise
Preston talked with the family members
who want to see police video from the
chase which is prompting protests in
that City
[Applause]
an accountability the family of Tyree
Nichols is demanding answers from the
Memphis Police Department after they say
the 29 year old was beaten by police
during a traffic stop
[Music]
Memphis Police say that on the night of
January 7th officers attempted to pull
over a car for reckless driving which
led to a confrontation they say the
suspect then fled on foot leading to the
second confrontation once under arrest
police said the suspect complained of
shortness of breath and was taken to the
hospital the Tennessee Bureau of
Investigation is investigating a
possible use of force by Memphis police
police have not said how many officers
were involved in a statement on Sunday
the Memphis police chief said after
reviewing various information involving
the incident the officers were serve
notices of impending administrative
action the internal investigation is
expected to be completed this week what
do you want from Memphis Police today uh
we need your videos your body calves any
type of video of the incident released
we want Justice we want the officers to
be charged with murder we don't want
them to just get fired his stepfather
took this photo of Nichols in the
hospital shortly before he died to see
Tyree in that condition oh it took more
than my breath away the truth is going
to come out Attorney Ben Crump is
representing the family if you have
nothing to hide why not release the
video for CBS mornings I'm Elise Preston
let's have to look at those pictures